does the Prime Minister agree with me
that the time for such live television
debates at general election times has
now come and William and will he agree
to hold television debates with the
leaders of the main political parties so
that people can see us discuss the
issues the policies and the challenges
for the future of this country you
either want to have a television debate
or you don't want to have a television
debate I do want to have one I think
it'd be good for our democracy good for
our politics good for the general
election so I hope that Gordon Brown
this week will get off the fence and say
they'd hear a greater one I've always
believed in live television debates I
think they can help enliven our
democracy I think they will help answer
people's questions I think they will
help crystallize the debate about the
change this country needs there are two
credible sets of debates you can either
have a debate with all the national
parties who appear in this house or you
can have a debate or vote have a debate
between the two people who'd become
Prime Minister those are the credible
debate so I asked him again when he
looks at the Green Party why is he so
scared I say let's have these debates
let's get on with them before the
election
you
you